[Música]
eeuu 800 millones de dólares adicionales
para ayuda militar a ucrania así lo
anunció el presidente joe biden quien
poco después llamó criminal de guerra a
su homólogo ruso vladimir putin el
kremlin respondió que esto es
inaceptable e imperdonable
los pronunciamientos de biden y putin
ocurrieron después de que el presidente
ucraniano volodymyr selenski lidera el
congreso estadounidense en una zona de
exclusión aérea sobre ucrania para
contrarrestar los bombardeos rusos les
explicaremos por qué occidente se niega
a la petición
más de 1000 civiles se resguardaban en
el teatro en mariupol que fue
bombardeado según autoridades locales
ucrania responsabiliza a rusia pero
moscú lo niega y culpa a milicias
ucranianas sin dar evidencias mientras
tanto del ejército ruso sigue cercado
aquí es
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
yo soy maría clara calle y es un placer
acompañarlos el presidente de eeuu joe
biden anunció un nuevo paquete por 800
millones de dólares de ayuda militar y
humanitaria a ucrania que incluye
armamento defensivo radares y tecnología
antiaérea el flujo de armas de
washington y sus aliados ha sido
constante desde el inicio de la invasión
al punto que en la última semana la casa
blanca ha dado más de 1000 millones de
dólares a kiev
continuamos con el flujo de armas y
municiones hacia ucrania y utilizando mi
autoridad presidencial
active mayor asistencia de seguridad
para ayudar a ucrania a frenar el ataque
ruso con 800 millones de dólares
adicionales eso lleva la asistencia a
mil millones de dólares solamente esta
semana
esos son transferencias directas de
equipos desde nuestro departamento de
defensa para ayudarlos a luchar en
contra de esta invasión después de su
anuncio el líder de la casa blanca habló
con los periodistas y afirmó que su
homólogo ruso vladimir putin era un
criminal de guerra baiden es el primer
mandatario estadounidense que ha llamado
así a putin esto fue lo que dijo
señor presidente después de todo lo que
hemos visto está listo para llamar a
putin un criminal de guerra
por qué no
me preguntaste si lo diría
[Aplausos]
creo que es un criminal de guerra
el kremlin respondió que las
calificaciones contra vladimir putin
eran inaceptables e imperdonables por su
parte del presidente ruso aseguró que
logrará sus objetivos en ucrania y que
no se someterá a lo que llamó un intento
occidental de desmembrar a rusia
escuchemos al jefe del kremlin
no tuvimos más remedio que comenzar la
operación militar especial como defensa
propia para la seguridad de rusia todos
nuestros objetivos se lograrán los
problemas que son fundamentales para
rusia para nuestro futuro como la
neutralidad de ucrania la
desmilitarización y la desnazificación
de ucrania estábamos y estamos listos
para discutir los los pronunciamientos
de wyden y putin ocurrieron horas
después de que el presidente ucraniano
volodymyr selenski interviniera en el
congreso estadounidense a través de una
videoconferencia allí el mandatario
reiteró una petición que la casa blanca
y la otan han negado y es declarar una
zona de exclusión aérea sobre ucrania
para evitar los bombardeos rusos
previamente iván lópez miralles analista
de política álbum nos explicó desde
españa que es una zona de exclusión
aérea y por qué occidente se niega a
concederla
no se trata de no estamos hablando de
una zona exclusión aérea sino que
estamos hablando de imponer una zona de
exclusión aérea y esto implica que hay
que realizar patrullas constantes sobre
territorio ucraniano hay que movilizar
un gran número de aeronaves y aunque un
escenario idílico esto no significa que
un enfrentamiento directo con moscú
podría significar una escalada nuclear
como ya hemos presenciado con la
señalización relativo al grado de alerta
de sus fuerzas estratégicas no pero para
que la efectividad de la descripción
aérea sea realmente efectiva deben
derribarse los aviones y helicópteros
rusos en vuelo no lo que evidentemente
pues implicaría un choque directo de la
otan con moscú a esto además hay que
sumarle la neutralización de las propias
amenazas a los aviones de la otan es
decir hay que localizar destruir los
sistemas antiaéreos que rusia tiene
desplegados en territorio ucraniano ya
sea misiles de tierra aire baterías
antiaéreas radares y no sólo eso sino
también habría que neutralizar los
sistemas desplegados
ruso y bielorruso por lo que podrían
suponer una amenaza no por lo tanto
estamos hablando de que esta exclusión
aérea hay que estar dispuestos a
disparar ya que se disparen como bien ha
afirmado el portavoz del pentágono john
kirby por eso los países de la otan y de
eeuu son tan reticentes a la
implementación de una exclusión aérea
porque significaría una tercera guerra
mundial con con rusia y rusia ya
señalizado que esta tercera guerra
mundial sería de carácter nuclear y
precisamente los bombardeos han sido una
de las estrategias militares más usadas
por los rusos para atacar a las ciudades
ucranianas en sus pantallas en amarillo
verán los puntos que moscú atacó el
miércoles es que las fuerzas rusas
intentan avanzar hacia la capital kiev
desde el noreste del país pero han
enfrentado resistencia mientras que las
autoridades de mariupol afirmaron que en
el teatro que fue bombardeado había al
menos 1000 civiles los ataques ya dejan
decenas de muertos
con tiza blanca en este teatro de
mariupol escribieron la palabra niños en
ruso en el suelo en el que era el
refugio de cerca de 1000 civiles ahora
el edificio está destruido tras ser
bombardeado por las fuerzas rusas aún se
desconoce el número de víctimas según el
teniente de alcalde de la ciudad el
ministro de exteriores ucraniano dijo
que rusia sabía que su objetivo era un
refugio de civiles
otro horrendo crimen de guerra en
mariupol ataque masivo ruso contra el
teatro dramático donde se escondían
cientos de civiles inocentes el edificio
está ahora totalmente arruinado
imposible que los rusos no supieran que
se trataba de un refugio para civiles
salven a mariupol detengan a los
criminales de guerra rusos este es el
último de una serie de ataques rusos
contra edificios civiles y contra
civiles directamente en terni hill las
tropas abatieron a 10 residentes que
hacían fila para comprar pan algo
confirmado por el fiscal general de
ucrania la embajada de eeuu en kiev lo
señaló como un ataque horrible
hoy las fuerzas rusas dispararon y
mataron a 10 personas que se han fila
para comprar el pan en cherry hill este
tipo de ataques horribles deben parar
estamos considerando todas las opciones
disponibles para asegurar la
responsabilidad de cualquier crimen
atroz en ucrania en la capital las
operaciones de rescate se pusieron en
marcha tras el ataque ruso a dos
edificios uno de ellos de 12 pisos 37
personas fueron evacuadas rusia continúa
con intensos bombardeos en todo el país
incluyendo la ciudad sureña niccolai
restarme
la única opción que tienen es borrar
esta ciudad del mapa y sólo entonces
podrán pasar en teoría eso es posible
pero haremos todo lo posible para no
permitirlo
pero las tropas avanzan poco
obstaculizadas por la dificultad del
terreno local la guerra en ucrania
relegó a la pandemia los casos positivos
de coronavirus en todo el país habían
alcanzado sus máximos históricos con
unos 40 mil contagios diarios a mediados
de febrero pero desde que comenzaron los
ataques no se volvieron a reportar los
positivos
la guerra de ucrania eclipsó la pandemia
de kobe 19 desde el 24 de febrero cuando
dio inicio la invasión rusa ucrania nos
actualizan las cifras de contagios y
decesos por coronavirus que vivían su
pico máximo a mediados de ese mes sin
embargo los servicios sanitarios también
intentan hacer frente a otra batalla la
pandemia
la situación es difícil y tensa como
pueden ver gente enferma ventanas
tapadas bombardeos desde la mañana hasta
la noche
incluso antes de que comenzara la guerra
compramos suministros médicos así que
tenemos algunos ahora los voluntarios
también están trayendo por supuesto no
es la cantidad que nos gustaría tener
mucho más preparado el hospital clínico
regional de enfermedades infecciosas de
hardcore fue el principal centro de
tratamiento de pacientes de kobe 19 de
la región entre bombardeos el personal
sanitario ofrece asistencia a los
enfermos que con los sonidos las sirenas
se trasladan a los refugios terráneo si
incluso han conseguido material de
protección en caso de un ataque químico
estamos preparando máscaras de gas para
el personal y los pacientes de nuestro
hospital en caso de un ataque químico o
la situación más delicada la sufren los
pacientes de las unidades de cuidados
intensivos conectados a respiradores las
bombonas de oxígeno podrían explotar por
los aires en caso de un eventual
bombardeo el éxodo desatado con la
agresión rusa también ha dejado al
personal sanitario bajo mínimos hay
mucho personal que no logra llegar al
trabajo desde otras partes así que
intentamos funcionar con el personal que
tenemos los que logran llegar se quedan
aquí
en ucrania sólo el 35 por ciento de la
población estaba totalmente inoculada
contra el patógeno ahora con el kobe 19
relegado a un segundo plano preocupa que
la guerra provoque también un proto
masivo
sigan con nosotros
[Música]